hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to home from work - now this
is a horror game and a sequel to home
from work one which I cannot remember if
I play it or not or if oh oh oh I
thought that was the game oh boy okay
well this is a nice place sure I'm happy
I'm home from work
oh wish the mouse sensitivity was just
the slightest bit less with this under I
should probably have a flashlight ready
Oh left it on the kitchen island good
okay here we go
who did not expect that to actually open
there okay do I have a wife or or kids
or a friendly ghost that lives here
anything of the sort
I think that's gonna be a big negative
on them when big papa
I'm just gonna go ahead and proceed to
turn on the lights all throughout the
house which everyone knows is the
perfect way to stop demons from eating
you as soon as you turn on a light
negates all the demons instantaneously
oh no I have an act
I've and I have an attic why why why why
would hi was that my little scamp of a
kid I mean I'm in a house with like four
bedrooms you think I'd have someone else
living here [ __ ] that was dark I
ain't afraid of you okay I'm assuming is
the master bedroom maybe is this my
bedroom
hello why am i mysteriously checking
every room in the house can I go up to
the attic
no alrighty then okay
alright hey [ __ ] you no no no no I'm
gonna open the store and you're gonna
tell me who you are
tell me what you want what you really
really want anything in the attic aah
ohh ohh
seems like my lights are acting up again
what the hell is happening gee I don't
know but maybe I should go in the attic
hoop hoop hoop I'm up here now I've
sincerely regret my decision to come up
here but here I am and here is where I
will say hello hello ah hello ah the key
to the basement that I keep in the Attic
to so I can have a scavenger hunt for
myself every once in a while ok then
oh no you don't oh don't do it
I [ __ ] you I knew it I knew it I'm
not afraid of you
so these are all Bork to Nordahl them no
longer working but I got my flashlight
and 70% battery left I didn't need the
basement key then did I because you're
just gonna open up already right nice
yeah this is oh good oh good it's that a
ghost breathing on my neck err is that
supposed to be me right now because one
is welcome and one is cowardice lovely
oh boy oh boy what the [ __ ] was that
nothing it was a whole lot of nothing
whoa okay it's a staying it's nothing
Lebowski I did it I fixed my lights just
as I had always intended now cuz the
thing could stop breathing on me that'd
be great
I'm gonna go back upstairs now because
what could possibly happen to be next
hopefully nothing horrifying [ __ ] hi
who's in my house or was that in your
house honestly who can tell oh boy
who's gonna take my time up these stairs
very slowly
hello somebody upstairs why did this
kitchen
go out I didn't turn this off oh okay
there we go
all right then it's just [ __ ] with me
oh you're just digging with me oh I see
you're just [ __ ] with me you're
turning things off hello hi my name is
markiplier walking hi I don't have a
baby I don't even have a wife I live in
this big four bedroom by myself
[Music]
[Applause]
hi Oh what is that [ __ ] hi see this
table oh no [ __ ] right okay then
that's not cool [ __ ] you what the [ __ ]
it's gonna break my eardrums on me what
was that and I don't have any commentary
on that I'm just gonna be like ah the
furniture floating again I see that
every Tuesday all right so I'm gonna go
back upstairs now I'm not gonna think to
get out of this house we could go back
upstairs and see what's for up here oh I
think you fell all right can't go to bed
yet can I just can I just go to bed oh
it's dark up here but I don't think
there was ever any light [ __ ] high
okay don't do that to me you sack of
[ __ ] don't do that to me
don't [ __ ] do that to me I don't like
that at all okay yeah [ __ ] hi okay
alright that's normal
[Applause]
all right you just keep squealing off
into the darkness I'm going to go down
to the basement because hi
what is the glowy Oh what is the glowy
pray tell wall [ __ ] me oh no I don't
want to do that
mmm I don't want to do that all right
okay all right there's a chair here does
he sit on that no okay I'm gonna go down
here okay don't know why chairs are so
spooky
they were my allies in amnesia okay well
that's okay
Oh what's with the chewy goopy what are
you doing okay I get it you're crying
like a little [ __ ] but it's okay you
got markiplier here the bravest youtuber
there is all right let's go back and see
what it was behind the red spooky okay
all right nothing apparently apparently
a whole lot of nothing it's just as
chair that's out of place alrighty then
what was that what was I did not I did
not click anything oh no oh no I don't
have enough battery for this oh no oh no
running out of battery right now right
about now funk soul brother anything up
here no I'm dead I got no battery the
[ __ ] what am I supposed to
there's no more red chair glowy
oh-oh-oh-oh
scary oohs Oh skid Ian's I don't know
what to do whoa whoa hi hello hi okay
all right then
now I'm completely lost I went into the
basement and I have no idea what's going
on
okay all right then I'm gonna skedaddle
out of here okay so I had to I had to
get back into the game now I have a
plenty of battery left
I am completely on battery power now
that chair is toppling red I'm a good
answer to see if I can find me some eyes
hello hi whoa [ __ ] high okay then
try this again nope okay what am i doing
I have no idea okay I don't know okay I
guess I'm going back upstairs before I
run out of battery no hello hi knocking
hi what are you doing I don't know what
it was Andy was all right yesterday but
now he is Mandy remarks was always
staying late from work with his friend
who also seemed to be having problems
with himself
not long ago did his friend did die by
something possessing his home oh maybe
possessing him ever since Andy came back
home from visiting his friend he told me
he heard noises at night which he could
not explain it started with minor
something then progressed a banging and
lastly now his death this leads me to
believe whoever enters the home of the
devil will soon be killed in your own
home because I possibly be next
oh yeah I think that's a certainty I'm
at the end I ran out of battery like two
seconds before the end was actually
supposed to be
there oh man I'm a dick alright but
anyway so I think I think that's it
nothing more to be done so anyway that
is home from work - I can't remember if
whoo thank you for playing home from
work - so that is home for work - so
thank you everybody so much for watching
let me know what you thought down the
comments below tension mode just says
the monster is present from the
beginning the devil itself is chasing
after you so maybe if you want an extra
challenge with this game along with the
spooks you can play that for yourself so
thanks again everybody so much for
watching let me know what you thought
this down becomes below and as always I
will see you in the next video bye
[Music]